uh we can hear now from our state
department correspondent rosn Jordan who
is live in Washington DC so rosn uh what
sort of reaction has there been
obviously very early in the hours in the
morning where you are has there been any
official reaction now coming from the
United
States well there was a reaction that
came earlier from the US Embassy in
Jerusalem uh telling US citizens to uh
engage in uh security precautions to be
very careful in their movements Embassy
staff have basically uh been uh told not
to uh go anywhere or do anything uh they
have been accounted for and then in the
past few minutes we have received a
statement from the White House from NC
spokesperson Adrien Watson the US
unequivocally condemns the unprovoked
attacks by Hamas terrorists against
Israeli civilians there is never any
justification for terrorism and of
course our viewers will will recall that
the US designated Hamas a terrorist
organization back in 1997 because of
threats posed against uh Israeli uh
interests and by extension in the US's
view against us interests in the region
and so it's it's not surprising I would
anticipate that officials both at the
White House and at the state department
perhaps at the Pentagon as well may have
been uh Consulting with their uh
Partners in the region since this attack
happened overnight East Coast time